Film Courage: You are sitting in traffic on
Wilshire Boulevard.
I’m sure it was a lovely Los Angeles intersection
with lots of commotion [recounting how he
developed the idea for his feature scifi film
AFTER WE LEAVE], was this your first feature
script that you were planning to write?
Or had you written prior feature scripts?
Aleem Hossain, filmmaker and AR/VR creator,
assistant professor in media arts and culture
at Occidental College: I had written many
feature scripts.
Most of them I had written right after I got
out of film school.
Largely with an eye for trying to sell them
or get them set up to be produced sort of
within the studio system, a few of which I
even liked.
Some of them I’m glad I wrote just because
I think you need to write a certain amount
of bad scripts just to get to a better script.
But yes I had been writing a lot and with
a few things that I had been well-received,
I was still running up against the roadblock
of people saying this is a potentially makable
script but not with you as a director.
You’ve never directed a feature.
No one is going to take that risk.
And so AFTER WE LEAVE was my answer to that
recurring complaint.
I was like “Fine, if that is the case I’m
just going to go make my own movie and get
that one excuse out of the way.
I will be a feature filmmaker by making my
own film and then I can hopefully return and
get something bigger budget off of the ground.”
Film Courage: And these were producers that
you were pitching that were saying this?
Aleem: Producers, agents and never by the
way in a mean way.
I think appreciate of the work that I was
trying to do and interested in the stories
that I wanted to tell.
But just being frank about the reality of
who they were going to entrust “X” dollars
with and that it would be a hard fight for
someone who hadn’t made a feature.
Which is sort of a catch-22 right?
We talk a lot about access to the industry
and if the access point is how come you haven’t
already made something we get caught in this
vicious circle.
And so I just wanted to break out of that.
For me the solution was just making a very
small budgeted film that I could direct and
craft in the way that I wanted which again
I did primarily as a form of self-expression.
I made the movie not as a career calling card
primarily, not as a strategic movie in Hollywood.
I made it because I just wanted to tell that
story.
I think the benefit is it now makes me a director
in a lot of people’s eyes and it has opened
more doors but it wasn’t really my main
reason for doing it.
Film Courage: Speaking of access…and I know
we are taking a little bit of a…we are diverging
a bit.
Aleem: That’s fine.
Film Courage: What are some of the misconceptions
whether they are from students or other people
in the industry about access and what have
you seen from going through this process yourself,
being told this yourself that you can’t
do it.
Aleem: I think if we are specifically talking
about feature films, I think the biggest problem
with access is that the business entirely
has changed since a lot of us fell in love
with movies.
There are just so many fewer smaller movies
being made but the studios and the big production
companies that I have to think that opportunities
for new directors or less experienced directors
aren’t even there.
I actually think that a lot of that access
problem is they are not in the business of
making those movies that they used to give
to a younger director.
They are just making these huge movies.
That being said I definitely think for sure
the overall industry has biases against and
they are structural biases, they are biases
that come not from necessarily bad intentions
but there are barriers to women, to people
of color, for sure.
I think the hope right is that there is an
antidote to that where we can now make our
own content.
And I do think that that is a valid idea.
That the way around the access problem is
to make stuff.
But I think the funny thing these days is
I don’t know if the model anymore is make
a low-budget film so you can then jump up
to a lower mid-budget studio movie.
Because those don’t even exists.
I think that really I have sort of re-thought
how I think about my career.
I’m just going to keep making movies.
I don’t actually expect there to be this
moment where all of the sudden where now I
don’t have to self-produce or at least partially
self-produce my own movies because I don’t
know if that path exists anymore.
I really think that if I want to make these
movies then I will make them.
The career of directing movies in Hollywood
there are so few films made these days that
I don’t know that that is a path that one
sort of incrementally gets to.
Sometimes you make a film good enough on your
own and you get that lightning strike and
you can level up in a big way.
But I don’t think there are more incremental
steps because I think there is nothing in
between.
Film Courage: When your students come to you
with questions about access are you telling
them the same thing basically?
Don’t try to make something just so you
can get to that next level so someone can
“endorse” you?
Aleem: I mean the very first thing that we
talk about at Oxy [Occidental College in Los
Angeles, California] that the skills involved
in filmmaking and media making we don’t
think of those as skills that are inclusively
for Hollywood.
I think we live in a world where the ability
to tell your story and express yourself visually
is something that everyone needs to do.
Individuals, companies, non-profits, governments,
cultural institutions, all of them need to
do that.
So I think of this toolbox (artistically and
logistically) that we are giving people in
the classroom as applying to a huge amount
of life.
When we talk specifically about access to
Hollywood I do tell people that I don’t
think that film director is a career.
I think film director is an aspiration.
I think independent film director is a calling
or I wish I had a better word than hobby because
I don’t think it’s a hobby.
But I don’t actually think it’s a career
path.
I think it is a thing one does because you
are compelled to do it.
If you were to corner even who you think of
as a successful independent director and ask
them “Do you pay your mortgage with filmmaking
income this year?”
So many of them will say no and that is just
the reality.
That is not a reason to stop making movies.
It’s a reason to ask myself “Why am I
making movies?”
If you are making movies because you just
feel compelled to do it, that is the right
answer.